would you give me um a group test Esther
a what a group test to see where I'm at
in my cycle
sure
can you really yeah yeah do it okay I
dare you we're getting this you guys
this is our pre-live show show Okay so
let's give you a little taste of what
the live show is going to be like hold
on just just keep in mind should I go
wash up first are you okay no Esther's
never washed I'm a little dirty but you
can no Take Back the Night for all the
guys that have had to touch her nasty
slimy hairy hairy vagina well okay so
I'm gonna scoop it and why are you
asking me I thought you were the pro
you're the one who says you can tell
when any what wait where a girl is on on
her cycle just by doing the can I just
say something you are such a [ __ ]
people pleaser that you asked her if you
wanted to watch if you wanted her to
have you wash up not her nasty dirty
little finger she's literally wiping her
nose that is true I would I have to say
like I am a little bit strict about like
having it
clean before yeah you look like a clean
[ __ ] little baby I doubt it did you get
up on the sink what did you just use a
wipe is it something that I use it a
rigorous wiping
yeah I'll do a wet wipe I always have
baby wipes I have a bidet
I have a I object I think that's
actually not very good for you any of
the baby wipes just go with just clean
solid water
I think it [ __ ] up [ __ ] with your pH
okay but what if I'm just out on the go
and I want to get [ __ ] by your fiance
in a bathroom at UCB theater well it's
like I like what are you talking about
why'd you have to make us a UCB cup
because we've been in there because
we've been we started the theme you're
an improviser I thought I thought those
were your legs like this is what I think
well I was over here I literally was
like is she just lifting her legs all
the way up to the ceiling wait are we
gonna are we should we open
I don't know how to do that are you
gonna tell what this is how I've gotten
by in life are we talking about these
things that's not what I meant wait and
this is how I've gotten by in like
enclosed crossed
what if I told you that you could grow
thicker healthier hair and also support
this show go to neutriful.com use code
trash to save 15 off your first month
this is their best offer anywhere only
available to us customers for a limited
time free shipping on every order that's
15 off at
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com code trash if you've
ever wondered whether your CBD was
working that means it probably wasn't
next Evo Naturals developed smart sorb
technology clinically proven to help
your body absorb CBD four times better
than regular CBD oil because oil just
doesn't mix with your water-based body
it works faster too when you feel stress
coming on you won't waste time wondering
is it working get to the root of stress
with the stress CBD complex from next
Evo Naturals for up to 25 off
subscription orders of forty dollars or
more use promo code trash Tuesday at
next Evo dot com that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code trash
Tuesday ZocDoc is a free app that shows
you doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance and are available
when you need them go to zocdoc.com
trash and download the ZocDoc app for
free then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that
z-o-c-d-o-c.com trash
zocdoc.com trash you guys in two days
November 17th this Thursday we are doing
our second live stream and it's gonna be
sexual sexual interactive it's gonna be
hilarious it's gonna be so fun it's
gonna be wild amazing do not miss it get
your tickets you do not want to miss out
on this okay you want to be in the slug
Club you gotta be in the slug Club okay
go to moment.com trash Tuesday
interactive we'll see you there hi slugs
my tour is my mini tour is very close
you can get tickets at Esther onice.com
I'm coming to Portland Seattle San
Francisco and Phoenix I cannot wait
tickets at astronauts.com see you there
you can see me November 18th and 19th I
will be in Plano Texas I'm back at the
house of Comedy I can't wait to see you
guys again and then I am uh in Vegas for
New Year's and there's more dates all of
the beginning of December I'm going to
be in Michigan a bunch of dates please
go to my website you guys Annie wood my
solo podcast is right after the show so
click over to my YouTube when you get a
chance
I have to figure out why you're matching
the chair perfectly do you understand
new match literally the perfectly into
the chair am I camouflaged can you see
me where is she you don't no she'll
always find it don't worry this creep
there she is wait I have I actually have
a legitimate question I have one too
it's kind of considered like lonely
season right now um yeah cuffing season
because yeah so it's it's I think though
the Prelude to coughing season is
huffing season lonely season
and I'm just curious like loneliness is
a big theme in my life you know and I
like to talk about it and if you guys
have any times where you've been lonely
or if you're feeling lonely and how you
cope I shut with the door open I have
not been wrong in years okay
let me see I have definitely been a
perpetrator of the cuffing season
um when the seasons change I get
seasonal affective disorder and I like
to latch on to people like my mouth I
might let go of in the spring really I
think so well it's not even like you
mean to do it right it's like you just
kind of are like in you're like things
your hot chocolate is around it's like
harder and I feel like California I also
just get real cuddly I think when the
when it gets a little cooler so I just
like to again loaf around in bed with
somebody but then Summer's back you can
go diving you're like I gotta leave
ditch this lump not a whole lot of
diving options in the winter so I I'd
rather dive into some dick you know did
I ever tell you my women's March faux
pas no this is when you wear the [ __ ]
hat oh that was actually so embarrassing
the women's March was embarrassing for
me I'm sorry women I
I I was embarrassed by it I'm sorry I
love you sorry
but I was humiliated by it but during it
you know all the chance you know I'm a
loud [ __ ] so I loved the chance like
when people would like start the chance
right so I love to be the one amplifying
the chance so I heard
um no more Texas and I was like oh my
God that's really harsh but okay no more
Texas I started screaming no more Texas
and my friend that was with me was like
what are you saying I was like I'm
saying no more Texas and she goes
they're saying show your taxes I just
can't believe they got it wrong
over your reading comprehension skills I
was like got in the way I literally was
like [ __ ] Texas I guess I love Texas
though the day of that one that big
women's March I know like the first big
one
I woke up that morning and found out my
grandfather passed away and so me and
Dave went out to brunch and I remember
being like wow like I can't believe we
got a table like this is so lovely and
and then I realized it's because it was
the women's March and so all the
brunches were busy and that's so funny
that women were willing to like take a
brunch off
I think I was still drunk but I like
yeah I really I profited I benefited off
of the women's march by getting a good
brunch table and I got a really cute
[ __ ] hat that's sort of like
actually enjoying LA for the first time
Coachella weekend yes and
um Burning Man weekends literally I'm
this is me releasing a gate kept thing
that I wouldn't say but I want the fans
of our show to know this if you guys
ever wanna have a great weekend in La
come during Coachella it's so much
emptier because all the idiots have got
no disrespect but all the idiots have
gone to Coachella and like there's less
traffic all the cool places there's no
weights it
there's no weights at the gym
Esther loves it have you not experienced
that I mean I guess I'm usually on the
road
um I'm not that wasn't a disc but I
really am usually not around for it I
usually am flying and then hearing
people get pissed off during Coachella
and during
um burning man because they can't get
the flights they want I usually just
hear people complaining about that and
also Christmas time has the same effect
in La yeah oh you're right you're right
yeah well do you celebrate Christmas at
home you do right yeah yeah did you ever
get to decorate a tree yeah because my
mom is was not Jewish and so we did
Christmas oh nice and I remember my dad
was like like he says that that was hard
for him like he was almost embarrassed
that if people would see the tree from
the window because it just was so not
like how he was raised in that house but
he was oh it's his house
what at your dad's house yeah that you
still go to yeah don't no my eyelid
the house the basement that you live in
that is the house that my dad also grew
up in oh that's so cute I grew up that
is cute yeah so you still don't quite
feel welcome it's like you're visiting
no I feel extra welcome because I'm the
only grandchild
now what happened so how old was your
your dad never moved out or he moved out
and then re-bought it no he he moved out
and then when they passed away he moved
back in I have uh a question about your
daddy
um his relationship with his ex
your sister's mom what's that like no
your sister's your mom's right yeah oh
sorry so your mom's relationship with
her ex right your sister's dad
they don't they've never I've never seen
I don't think they have seen each other
in person or spoken like ever he's just
not in the picture no do you know his
name yeah I know him I've met him oh
he's fine does he like you he's chill
you know we're chill does he like you
more or less than your grandmother
definitely I don't know anyone who likes
me less than it's so funny because
you're competing with her what her old
lady energy he's stealing her Thunder I
think it's just she's just the
definition of like we all have this in
our lives where people will only know
you as how they first knew you and
that's what it is with her and me
but I don't know if I told you guys this
but this last time when I went to visit
my grandma's house in Minnesota
I it was the first time I had been with
her since I discovered
THC and it kind of made me see her
differently because she does alcohol is
her thing and I'm like oh like I do kind
of get it because I love
getting high because I'm like it's fun
and it's like an escape and then it made
me have empathy for her that like oh
well she just wants like to feel that
fun feeling Maybe
what do we think of this is this a weird
thing to say I'm not really insecure and
embarrassed no you're just high no I I
really wanted to stay locked in to that
story but I could go round off it was
boring I got lost and then I have now I
have guilt in my chest no she was being
born it's like when you read your poetry
and we're like too boring I lost
Grandma's probably an alcoholic and
she's not getting the same thing out of
you vaping weed like if she's like he's
angry again
he's like 80 and drinking every night
she's [ __ ] alcoholic but are you yeah
yeah yeah so she's just getting up
like how I do when I smoke weed you're
not an addict like me and your grandma
are are you trying to [ __ ] my grandma oh
my God yeah why are you like grouping
yourself with her grandma wait is that
why you're dressed like it from the
1920s there are a lot of single women in
my family right now grandma and they're
not Jewish too doesn't he look like he's
in the movie Her doesn't he look like
he's dressed like he's in the movie Her
well that's a good thing look it up
what's this Dr Phil thing
oh just sitting here let me pull it up
why is Dr Phil the most well-lit
celebrity iPad in front honestly I've
literally never this is something I
would have expected Whitney to ask him
when we were on like this is wild look
at him oh my god do you think he comes
with like a a ring light he looks so
good he looks beautiful he looks
gorgeous I've never seen a better P you
need to light us better what the [ __ ]
honestly look how gorgeous as Dr Phil
as good looking as him yes Dr Phil made
our new friend famous bad baby oh that's
right oh no don't bring that up it's my
fault how is she what is she like bad
babies that makes more sense can I tell
you this it's if this is a good story I
swear
I well we'll see if we what is this
gonna end with me like yanking you by
your pigtails so bad baby work today on
the movie and I was really excited to
meet her because I just love like
the people that are famous for nothing
yeah and so I went up to her shoes in
the makeup chair and I'm like hi
Danielle because that's her real name
I'm like I am Esther I'm so excited to
meet you thank you so much for doing
this if she Kylie Jenners you I'm going
to be sure I mean Kendall Jenner just
wait thank you so much like I am so
happy you're here
oh sorry do you have your headphones in
no okay
oh my God
no oh no she didn't acknowledge oh yeah
she lives up to her name she iced me out
and literally I'm like this is my movie
and there's someone on the set who won't
look at me like this and then you had to
do a scene with her it was probably your
best scene ever I like her even more now
I like her even more now
yeah Esther thrives and I did and it
really got me like high and amped up and
obviously by the end of the night she
warmed up to me and we were good and I
want I just want to say like I get it
this girl is 19 she has been through a
lot in the public eye and like if that's
if she has to have her Handler speak to
me for her that's okay
I also just think with the sting it's a
sting I don't think it's a sting Esther
it shouldn't be a sting because she
lives up to exactly who she you know she
is bad she's that we can't expect she
would be great it would be boring if
everyone was also how disappointing
would it be if she was actually not that
girl and if she was like hello Esther
really nice to meet you you'd be so
disappointed
like if she came up with like do you
want to do a tick tock together
but you try but that no but that is a
good point and I actually like that it's
like we instead of us all being fake
characters and then professional we
should all just be slobs and be who we
are well I have to tell you like what I
love so much about reality TV and when I
keep meeting all of these I've met
another guy from The Challenge which one
I met turbo it's like I met him I know
him Turbo's new he he won the Survivor
in another country let me see which one
wait can I also say while we were
shooting the scene
um bad baby spent 36 000 on clothes
who did it remind you of
and that we all realized that was more
than the budget of the movie that day
cost like she just spent to that [ __ ] I
thought you're gonna set the budget of
the movie I was like oh boy this is
gonna be crazy
this I met turbo he's from Turkey the
challenge turkey yeah he won the
Survivor turkey he's won a bunch of the
challengers he's like a superhero there
but so he like an action star wait so
you you also know all the famous I know
every single person on the challenge I
keep meeting them you watch Turkish
reality no no he they they bring them
all from other places but I I'm not
above it I just you know I don't like to
read so if they're subtitles I'm not
going to be interested but
he okay so I saw him we were at the
Grove and I was like Todd do you want
Mama to buy you a cell phone
um I was like what does baby want
um I just love to spoil my bow I want to
be spoiled rotten like that I know I
must feel so nice he likes it he does
like it well he helps me with everything
it's like he's I pretty much have like
he's like finished his Netflix show and
I'm like do not get another show I will
pay for your life does it give you this
is a dopamine rush for you to spend for
something I have a Daddy Warbucks
complex I think I do too I like to I
really do like to get people things and
you know I like to send things
anonymously too it's not always about
the re I just like to make people happy
oh is that you the lump of coal at my
doorstep today yes that was actually a
piece of [ __ ] that I lit on fire I guess
you didn't get it in time I still have a
balloon to pick with you
unfortunately I was hoping you would
stomp it out with your shitty tiny
little ballerina dead girl shoes a
couple weeks ago deceased child slippers
a couple weeks ago you tweeted and you
were trying to set me up with let me
make sure that this is correct oh God
Adnan Syed oh that's so funny don't you
think that this famous podcaster or a
famous you of course should come a
famous podcast that would be what she
thought this famous uh icon in the world
of podcasting and which is our business
don't you think it only makes sense that
in this Multiverse or whatever you call
it when odd non-side is freed and kalila
is single at the same time it only makes
sense it's almost like you're the gift
that we give but the week before you
tweeted Elon should put a baby in me so
like where are we going are you just
pawning me off yes kalilah yes I am
projecting all of like because I haven't
been single in 10 years I'm like these
are all the things
the thing that I I would want to do oh
my God we would wrap you up you'd be
wearing the baby shoes we'd wrap you up
in a little Bonnet and ship me off to
Adnan
here's your little baby actually I think
it should be a threesome or foursome
wait me Adnan who else you me and Annie
no you don't get to cast me in this
you cast me in this trash
um I'm so glad you are ignored and
treated like [ __ ]
treats you like trash because you know
who would have treated you like a queen
just kidding but it does that got weird
you guys believed it but it does uh it
does I do thrive in it I like to be
rejected that's what people don't
whenever anyone's like worried about you
getting I'm like I like I don't think I
go hard enough on you I think I'm
starting to just do the hits and not and
Not only was it a rejection it was a
humiliation because it was in front of
all the people who in theory work for me
all these people are there for my movie
they work for me they had to watch me
it's the most entertaining you can be to
them too it's like for it's like it's
like um when you throw a stone into the
into a pond it just kind of Skips you
know it's like it's a story that just
gives like they went back to their
families and told them yes but what
scares me the most is that I felt like I
liked it I like being humiliated here I
think you knew cooking
you knew that bad baby was going to be
this way with you and I think you asked
for an audience
you made sure that people were around
you you made the move because you want
to be rejected in front of other people
I had I didn't I will assure you I did
not see this coming I did not see this
coming out you didn't see the kind or
the candle either I think you're cocky
that one handle might have worked
you needed you needed your fog I just
say I needed you but I can handle it
reject me to my face in front of
everything I don't allow it there was a
comedy club no there was a comedy club
where when I wasn't passed there this
there was a woman that worked there and
she wouldn't like make eye contact with
me
and I wouldn't allow her to not make eye
contact she'd look down and I would
squat under her face and make her make
eye contact with me I was like let's act
it out
oh my God this is really gonna be a lot
of crazy
hi I'm here I'm a person
hello
now she likes me so underneath okay
what's this Dr Phil thing wait but what
I was gonna say before about the reality
stars that I meet it's like you it
they're they're they don't disappoint I
don't need them to be anything other
than
what they've been on the show you know
like I don't expect like you know
they're all like sweeter than I know but
it's like if one of them like was like
[ __ ] you get away from me and that was
their character on the show I would be
like into it you know just be what you
are you like want an interactive
experience I just can't believe I keep
meeting them it's crazy I think you'd be
crushed if someone like Lady Gaga fully
rejected you
well I did meet her at a meet and greet
in 2009 and it did it was wasn't nice
actually tell us everything yeah how
long was the line how much were the
tickets was it a book signing she
invited you invited her to it was at the
Nokia Theater in LA it was right before
her show she had there was the meet and
greet and I guess you know she was early
and on and off in her career that I
thought like maybe a spark would form
but so delusional in 2009 to think that
2009 Lady Gaga was huge already they
actually already done the meat dress
no
no Esther's like I inspired that I I
told you that idea
um she didn't what honestly what hurt
was the sunglasses stayed on and I
really feel like the price of that
ticket was including eye contact no no
no no
honestly it reminded me that I've been
giving you too much are those guccis
yeah those are so good duh guys come on
these are old
I've had these for like three months
I've had 15 glasses since my by the way
did I tell you my
um the arm broke off of my Louis
Vuittons
and I and Yoni Tony's assistant who came
to me it was I don't know his producer I
don't want to say he's he's more than
that he's something magical
he went him and uh his assistant
I'm telling you I told this Dione I said
when I get an assistant because I want
to steal Yoni from Tony but it's like
he's attached it's not gonna happen I
love him so much Esther you'll die when
you meet him he's everything you're
making me want to steal him I'm telling
you he's it's like my whole goal in life
is like how rich do I have to take this
man how do you feel about this would how
would you feel if Esther a guy named
Yoni no what I'm saying how would you
feel if slowly little by little you see
Esther just start asking another guy all
of the things she normally and we like
kind of like slowly drifted apart a
little bit a little bit she's like
Carlos and you're like Esther let me do
this for you and she's like no thanks
like Yoni would like if you were having
like a problem in your relationship Yoni
would fix that too Yoni is like he's a
certification to do [ __ ] like that no
Yoni he does I'm telling you you need
transcends sort of Yoni could like come
from the ceiling down if you needed him
to like he's everything I'm telling you
he's everything Yoni or ever everything
he's everything I don't even know how to
explain it and honestly he's got it's
just it's every beautiful people I just
love them but I was telling him I was
like Yoni when I get an assistant I'm
sending them to Yoni boot camp like I'm
I will pay for them to go to Austin to
get trained by him and he can vet them
he can be like I want to get Yoni
training no but it's kind of like in the
gutter immediately a star in the trash
so you don't have what it takes I
actually think you don't know no no no
no no Esther no no you were meant to be
a pillow princess
you would know Yoni and you there's not
a drop of Yoni in you
not even an egg not even a Yoni egg he's
everything
Esther when they chopped your hair off
for season one of doll face did you cry
and cry and cry down that beautiful doll
face
um what were you getting to what what
did you take in order to get your full
name back look at this [ __ ] my hair is
so long and thick I love you neutrophil
you're my boyfriend neutrophils my
boyfriend anyone listen to Taylor Swift
yes okay another topic but lots of good
ones neutrophil is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage neutrophone is just an
easy addition to your daily routine you
take four pills a day for hair growth
baby and in a clinical study 86 of women
reported improved hair growth after six
months this is why I love neutrophil it
doesn't promise an overnight fix this is
something that I take every day and
um I just love the fact that in I don't
know like after a month I started seeing
results like all my baby hairs were now
pre-adolescent pre-adolescent hairs and
all her baby hairs are starting to get
pubes
thicker healthy
beautiful.com and entering the promo
code trash to save 15 off your first
month's subscription
this is their best offer anywhere and it
is only available to us customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get 15 off at neutrophone.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash you
guys I personally am really looking to
make CBD a bigger part of my life
because
the benefits are exactly what I need
because you're a water-based body I need
more relaxing I need more peace in my
life and that's why I love next Evo
Naturals because I trust them they're a
trusted Source they have like smart
sword technology is why Esther smart
sword technology improves cbd's ability
to be absorbed getting into your system
in as little as 10 minutes and most CBD
oil found in tinctures gummies or
capsules achieves between two percent
and 10 absorption which means more than
90 of what you think you're getting is
actually wasted I am so excited about
this because
I perform late at night it is
so stressful to have to try to go to bed
I'm so hyper my adrenaline is like
through the roof and I can never get to
bed till like two in the morning at
least and so I have been looking around
for a fast acting CBD and this is the
one it's like finally I can sleep I can
have a regular life oh and
um one of the one of the options that
you can purchase is the CBD complex with
ashwagandha it is clinically proven to
reduce stress by 70 ashwagandha and CBD
are a powerful combination working
together to Target the source of rising
stress and hormones like cortisol you
guys get to the root of stress with the
stress CBD complex from next Evo
Naturals for up to 25 off subscription
orders of 40 or more use promo code
trash Tuesday at next evo.com that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code trash
Tuesday
this is a time to take your shot skink
Fest Annie well do you want me to talk
about being molested
where's our Bell where is our Bell
actually I do want you to talk about
being molested thank you for offering
have I been molested are there any
molestations that you've kept in the
vault and have I remembered I remembered
one the other day I couldn't believe it
one popped up okay I was I was
24. I was living in maybe 23. I was
living in Santa Fe New Mexico I was
living at my friend Lizzie's house I was
living on her floor you can't live on a
phone
crawled around like you never came up no
no there was also like a bench that I
could sleep on but sometimes I'd roll
off so I slept on the floor but my
friend Lizzy she would let me sleep in
her bed too with her but you know you
had to give her a break if you come in
too late this guy who like
we had been friends maybe it was like a
little flirty but it was never like
a real thing you know we were just drunk
and somehow he came into the house with
me and I was like you can't be here I'm
like staying at my friend's house like I
can't have like guys in here and he was
like no no I'm just gonna sleep for a
little bit and I remember him sticking
his dick in man I was like said no over
and over and over again and then I
pushed him off me and he like went to
sleep or whatever but I remember being
like ew you tip raped me oh yeah but I
had I had I had completely forgotten and
I was like full nose the whole time like
don't come in like total boundaries and
I just was like so grossed I wish you
had crabs then Filipino were you guys on
the floor yeah it's hold on one second
so hold on you're sleeping on your side
and he just slips it from the side from
yeah well we were he was like lying next
to me
and then you're so [ __ ] up but it's
okay it's like remember when dudes would
like just beg you for just a tip when we
were younger no but this is why I quit
drinking I just ended up in so many of
these situations can I tell you that
this is what pisses me off so much is
that there is a breed of men and I have
learned this maybe the hard way that
like they think that being alone with
you means that you want to [ __ ] them
whereas I feel like I have been so
blessed with so many guy friends who I
can have sleepovers with all this stuff
I know I talk about this all the time no
one has ever none of my good guy friends
have ever tried that's so weird to even
consider but I've learned it the hard
way not everyone is like that and they
think that that just means that they
want that you want to [ __ ] them and
you're like what it was really it just
was like it was just like a thing where
it's like I just I just remembered it
it's like not something I'm traumatized
by it's not something but I remember in
the moment being like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you are [ __ ] dead to me
here's what else like there's no
question in the situation and it was
like full no no [ __ ] like giggling
around about it it was like [ __ ] you
dude one thing totally like when you
said like oh this is why you don't drink
because you end up in these situations I
think I can
speak to this not for myself but for the
male friends that were around me
um who were allegedly my friends
platonic never caught a Vibe always
thought they respected me but they were
always just a couple drinks away from
being inappropriate with me so it was
like by the end of the night there was
always someone either professing their
love for you there was someone forcing
the [ __ ] trying to kiss your neck and
that I really hated
17th birthday was a kegger at my house
thanks Mom and Dad
um it was a kegger at my house I'm so
sweet they like to have a question isn't
that cute my parents everything they've
done I realized in retrospect was just
out of pure love for me
I am like so good I just love these
people so sweet but I mean if you had
asked me like two years ago they [ __ ]
let me have a keg but um but so I had
this group of guy friends and this is
after that stuff happened with my
teacher I was like 16 when that happened
and then so I was turning 17. so this
was like you know a couple months later
they were my friends when we were at
court they were like threatening to go
kick the teacher's ass and stuff for me
which I like I had this like group of
guy friends
the night of my 17th birthday every
[ __ ] single one of them made a pass
at me every single one of them every
room I went to in my house was another
one of them
just rubbing a side pipe I was like are
you kidding me and it's okay it felt
like I just stopped being friends with
them I just realized that we're not
friends they were very helpful to me in
the time when I needed them and I and it
wasn't like mean but it was just like it
was disappointing but when this happens
with my male friends they're not even
saying oh kalila like let me hit on her
I'm just a female object like I think
they don't even know it's me but they
just when they just get real sloppy
that's where it just gets so [ __ ]
no thank you God I have I wonder if they
had a bet too I was like did you guys
have like were they like who's gonna get
her they're all just like waiting for
one of them none I've never I've never
I've never accidentally [ __ ] a friend
my um boyfriend in college said that
when I first came in as a freshman that
him and three guys were like May the
best man win really
wait what yeah
make you terrible or good it just was
funny because he was the only one that I
would dare have hooked up with like the
other ones were just like nothing like
they were just like not even had did not
have a chicken I do something disgusting
with dudes I like this is a confessional
right no one else is listening to this
yeah it's just if I really like a dude
I'm gonna absolutely try to hook him up
with one of my hottest friends
and I
see if they
do it or not and if they don't then I'm
like certain I want to like hook up with
them I've done this I've offered a dude
like six of my friends like hey like six
of my friends want to [ __ ] you and he
was like no thanks it's you're nagging
the guy I think I am because you're like
it's a subconscious way of saying well
I'm not into you you want her you want
yeah but that's still not adult that's
bullsh childish everything I'm saying is
embarrassing I think how old do you
think you are in this when you do this
Michelle Chalfont has the adult chair
she has the child chair the adult or
wait that oh what is it it's the baby
chair of the child please clip that
child chair can Carlos just look it up
for [ __ ] sake Michelle Chauvin it's
the
child chair the something thank you
adolescent chair the child chair of the
Adolescent chair and the adult chair
which show are you and are you in the
child chair of the Adolescent chair or
the adult oh I in one given day like
right now
when I'm doing that
oh adolescence for sure or pre like
tweenie yeah tweenie but
um somebody brought this up to me he was
like you know why trash Tuesday works
because in every entertaining setting
there was always a baby an animal and a
machine
oh my God which one am I but you can be
on it here I think your animal machine
you're all you're all of them and we're
just here no we can everyone's all three
of them so I think we need to designate
animal baby and a machine
I resonate with animal yeah yeah that's
it I think that's how he he had it in
his head too it's like that's why it's a
perfect combo
it is weird we are perfect that's so
cute
because we're very different from each
other yeah like you and I are so
different but then we have the like one
sickness of a similarity of like anxious
attachment or whatever else it is like
we somehow it's so nice together yes but
like were you I think a lot about like
what the [ __ ] is my problem what's wrong
with me and it's like oh I I want why do
I want and need so much attention like
is it because my parents like nobody
really interacted with me is that did
you also have that like were you alone
in your room a lot or like I wasn't
alone but I did feel very ignored a lot
like I felt very like there was just
like a lot of chaos going on and and
then the attention I got was always
negative did your mother prefer your
brothers yeah for sure I mean and not
like in a rude way but she just was like
into sports and stuff well I would also
have to guess pick me people always pick
me that boys are harder and I'm assuming
no they're easier they always say boys
are user I think later on in life
they're a little bit easier as babies
though they're yeah you're right they're
a little so I'm wondering if like it was
just the boys were more like no I was
thinking of killing themselves no I was
crazy I was the one that was wild huh
I always like needed something I was
like lactose intolerant so I was like I
had like even as a baby yeah and they
didn't like lactose intolerance wasn't
like a thing that doctors thought about
last that back then hey no that's what
this is what no it was the 80s Carlos
um the decade after
um I didn't know babies could be lactose
intolerant so you're I was like
constipated I was constipated all the
time I had like all you can be allergic
to the mother's milk really that means
yeah depending on what she's ingesting
especially if she's still breastfeeding
matching with the mom then and he should
have been I didn't breastfeeding you
didn't breastfeed at all
oh my brother did I didn't oh you
wouldn't latch yeah I'll teach you the
opposite opposite of someone else
wouldn't delatch very true I literally
remember it that is so funny how how she
was like the Time Magazine cover how
long did your mom breastfeed you after
three and a half were you wearing those
shoes when you were breastfeeding three
and a half
she's wearing her breastfeeding shoes
wow that's incredible go Mommy
yeah it's weird do you remember do you
have memories
should be around the max
did you sleep in bed with your parents
yes co-sleep isn't it funny that you
felt ignored but you kind of were
getting a lot of attention I think it's
both I know yeah it's both
I know what you mean because I got a lot
of attention too but I felt like really
kind of misunderstood well because I was
thinking the other day like I must have
been needing more because I would do a
thing where I would get all my stuffed
animals and like make everyone watch me
throw them down the stairs like that was
like the first like performance art I
did
so cute and I'm like why did I need why
did I feel the need to do that it's your
fault Mom and Dad
I would do this thing with my Barbies
the day after I got them uh-oh I would
ask for the
haha oh
he's scared I shoved up eight at a time
I um I would do this thing where I would
ask for that you remember the Barbies
with a hair all the way down to the feet
yeah they were very specific
um one that came out for like like a
couple years I would ask for those just
so that I could show my mom that I was
cutting their hair the next day
I would cut their hair I remember Lisa
went from hair down to her ankles to
like a bowl cut a bowl cut and then I
would like draw like take a red Sharpie
and put blood all over her [ __ ] was
that performance art yes that's very
Maria Brahma it's not performance art
it's art
yeah it's like you that Barbie was Art
is that art Nick art the clown have you
guys seen terrifier too shut up the
clown is very art the clown is that art
he's an artist like sure you could by
the by the way [ __ ] we all could
make [ __ ] like that and have an Art
Exhibit of bloody [ __ ] whatever no no
whatever your current version is we
should all we should have an artist oh
yes we should also have merch we should
also have a [ __ ] live show
oh gosh oh we do one date together we
could also do that is Vegas happening or
not I'm going there for New Year's I
have I've been to Vegas 15 times since
you guys Vegas and New Year is the
nightmare yeah I'll never do it again or
heaven what's the other side of a
nightmare Heaven
I don't think so I dream a dream yeah
under this
what is the opposite of nightmare Heaven
it is it's happening Helen Heaven are
opposite yeah I don't believe in hell
don't have Helen Jewish in Jewish Jewish
what do you know you just visit you just
dropped by every once in a while for the
cookies
so for the gelt she comes in for a
little Galt doesn't she I love those and
then she passes on through Jewish Phil
doesn't she I actually don't like gout
because I don't like plain chocolate
it's gold it's just when you grow up
with Reese's Peanut Butter Cups and then
someone gives you gout you're like [ __ ]
what
you should feel guilty about that I
should feel guilty
oh don't spread it that was how I if I
say a joke that's not that funny I go
like this after I wonder why bad baby
didn't want to talk to him laughs
oh my God I wish I could what the [ __ ]
did Dr Phil say yeah Carlos what the
[ __ ]
he's talking about colleges now and how
professors are being fired a bunch by
gen Z oh my God must well is he
God in heaven look at this man
you started seeing in
the universe oh my God is he okay start
seeing kids that are complaining he's
bidening something the professor
hurt their feelings it upset them
so they start going to the dean they
start going to the department head and
saying that professor said things that
upset me oh my God the drink break and
he took one sentence
professors
disciplined suspended or dismissed
in the last 10 or 15 years than we've
had since McCarthyism
because kids are going in there and
saying that hurt my feelings yeah he
offended really what's an example
because I'll give you an example I'll
give you up I believe it I also don't
get it would you want kids fly wild
children I'll say this it's your world
now get everyone fired
Dr Phil is so unreliable to me he's not
of the authority in anything but I
listened to this podcast on hidden brain
and there's a woman she was a professor
and also a psychologist but she talks
about the resilience of gen Z or the
lack of resilience of gen Z and like not
being afraid of even feeling anxious or
having a feeling is like a negative
thing anyways she uses an example of how
in at the University she was working at
one of the professors got fired for
sexual misconduct and they put out this
article talking about said Professor
about his sexual misconduct and the
amount of complaints that were filed
about students saying you should have
given us a trigger warning before
announcing the firing of this man for
sexual conduct misconduct so that I
actually it's sexual
they contact it's almost like
it's don't gender my conduct
but dude I think that's that's an
example of what he's saying Esther
misconduct was a beautiful young
she had beautiful little dead girl
slippers on little misconduct
honestly the kids are going crazy it's
hilarious let's see what happens are you
I just I just need to cut to the chase
are you for what he's saying I'm against
Dr Phil in general because I but I think
that he is talking about something that
is truly happening which is a lot of the
Gen Z kids are afraid of feelings well
the problem then is not on the kids it's
the [ __ ] people in charge firing
people they like the protocol needs to
be good let's get you in charge huh they
need me and they are doctor they need to
get her and bad baby up there in that in
those schools
[Laughter]
come and tame me
no honestly like I see what you're
saying but but I think everyone's so
afraid of getting fired that I'm not
Phil uh Phil Pete what's your name Dr
Pete talk she's morphing everything
are you in a place between
heaven and Nightmares I'm in a place
between your legs shut up
okay I have a question
wait what are poppers
oh I think um that is popular popular
for anal sex what is it it's like you
pop them and it's like a whippet sort of
right what is that it's the best thing
in the world we need whipped cream we'll
get whipped cream for the [ __ ] live
show someone answer me oh poppers
poppers yeah what are they poppers are a
type of inhalant that contain amyl
nitrite and butyl nitrite these products
cause blood vessel dilation I love a
blood vessel dilation something you get
high yes it's a quick and it makes your
butt relax so your butt is in the like
giggling okay guy gave it to me once oh
my God the stories are really unfolding
well I'm telling you the truth if he
gave me poppers he was trying to take
advantage of me but I just got high and
bolted really yeah I just want to know
is bolting when his penis fits perfectly
in your ass the amount of gay
experiences you've escaped is getting so
good Carlos I have a question would you
be open to having sex with a man no at
all no he's already had his [ __ ] open
to it and he escaped what I remember is
that you and kalila saw my [ __ ] like
six months ago yeah we did jog my memory
walk jog my memory I I wait didn't y'all
put something on my butt what did we put
a butt tape I actually always take a
hard drive
wasn't on the live
I don't know I was on the live yeah so
glad I didn't see
yeah
you know what is crazy is that I read
reviews for everything I do everything I
buy everything I consume whether it's
going to a restaurant things I'm buying
online I'm always searching for reviews
that's the most important thing it is
insane to think nowadays of going to a
doctor without reading a review first
you do not know what you're about to get
when you walk in the doctor's office and
you put in so much time and energy to
get there that it better be good that is
why zoc Doc is something I will not live
without and also it is such a deterrent
um to even see the doctor now that's
passion I need to go to a doctor after
that I have PTSD she was so heightened
well like imagine like needing to go to
the doctor but then sort of just like
just the the burden of having to find
one that you feel like you can trust I
mean I was so lucky before zogtalk I had
you and you're a doctor and it was in my
thing what it's true it's true will you
share the same doctor
you're a doctor no 50 things had to
happen for me to get to this freaking
doctor but you know what I mean it's
like this is that it's that it's like
having a friend that has a doctor in
your in your what is it called in your
network yeah and also it's like you
don't need to rely on Word of Mouth yes
anymore you can just go to this app and
there are um patient reviews that you
can sift through and see if it's the
right fit for you I've had just like the
rudest doctors I would have loved to
have skipped them it's like oh and now I
gotta deal with just like the anxiety of
you being mad at me and on sock talk you
can find every specialist Under the Sun
whether you're trying to straighten your
teeth fix an achy back get that mole
checked out or anything else ZocDoc has
you covered I want to get this mole
checked out thank you it has a tongue go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash
zocdoc.com trash it's free you gotta do
it
are you into SNM have you tried s m
stuff I haven't tried that but I don't
think how far have you you don't want it
to be like planned you want there to be
fear yeah I feel like fears you're not
like an RNA Army Hammer this is what's
going on I'll take you there he's
original army hammering
why are you laughing at that
because I feel like I don't I I have now
gone to the place where I am in the
audience's seat and I don't know what's
real and what's not
no that's all real
no I know I know I know I don't know
where the gay guys went but
they were there where did the gay guys
go Carlos
there was a gay guy there
we can't be that name he had a DUI in
Dallas why would you think
why is his name
because it does a lot of code you know
you can't Destin to be gay if you're in
last year
around me one more time I need a Dairy
Queen that is so rude are you hot treats
um are you hot eats or cold trees owned
when you got in that position Esther are
you hot East or cold treats you have to
pick one now only cold treats from Dairy
Queen are you cold or hot sandwich
hot cold for sure except I like a tuna
sandwich would you toast at Subway
quiznosis I 100 I toast I would not not
toast ugh you're trash
that's garbage Subway's amazing Subway
sucks and it's always like 47 I'm like
why would you because those was much
better I never had quizzes don't bring
up my dead finger Quiznos boy
that's the sandwich Annie was eating
when she met the guy who no he had the
sandwich just put it with me was very
generous and then he split Town one
solid topic
this is the No No to end to rap yeah I
think that's all you know what Tom Brady
is officially divorced and we're talking
about getting you with someone besides
Adnan I could see you with Tom Brady
he's really scared but what do we I have
good experience with athletes for sure
but um okay by the way I'm sorry with
the most definition of projecting just
happened on this show Carlos trying to
set Kyla up with Tom Brady and then
talking about how good his body is right
now
like I'm sorry but that was like it's on
it's unfolding just let it unfold wait
do you do you you want to [ __ ] Tom Brady
no I was like I'm all all about no he
only wants to [ __ ] college football
players wait Carlos are you loving him
right now because he's on a divorce diet
and he looks extremely skeletal yes I
love anyone he likes scallies I've been
not eating and if that's Tom Brady then
we're great now okay wait here what do
we think happened can we are we allowed
to like gossip our ideas what we think
happened of course now do you think he
cheated on her or do you think of course
he did well I mean I'm sure that's I
think that it was like a lot of people
are I feel like I'm sensing a lot of
breakups postcovid oh my God we got give
her her [ __ ] cards I think this was
one of them media Masters here guys
she's sensing things
all right awesome call on your
um Spirit guides tell us everything I
think it was a mutual and like they were
just both like let's be down no [ __ ]
way she's doing shady [ __ ] online like
she's commenting on like there was a
thing I saw that was like something like
you can't um you can't have a life with
someone that's like inconsistent with
you and should be like amen underneath
it and stuff like really
so I think okay what I the the PC like
obvious thing I think it is is that he
probably agreed to retire and be with
the family and then he went back he was
like [ __ ] it I'm here for bala's life
you know and then she was like [ __ ] you
I'm out still consistent well that's
that's what a lot of people think yeah
I've like that's such a hard situation
because I do feel like I want to support
him and his calling of wanting to like
play and he's breaking all these records
by being the oldest player like I
actually feel for him in that moment
because because you're going to be the
oldest teenager as the oldest teenager
if there are a lot of promises made
along the way and those none of them
were fulfilled I think that he held see
now Carlos you sound like a medium too
you both are kind of like channeling
your truth how old is he 40. something
anyways can we put crystal balls in
front of each of us for me so he's
like he's probably she didn't expect him
to play for the past six years probably
I'm getting injured beyond that it's
like when you are an athlete of that
level like your lifestyle is [ __ ] up
it's like that intensity that requires
you to be if oh my God I don't like it
oh my God I look at this he's 45. but at
45 to look like that yeah he looks hard
that's cool he's starting to look a
little bit like
you know what 45 year olds look like yes
I do like you Carlos even though you're
way younger than that
Dave is 44.
Dave's 44. wait you guys I have
something sad I want to talk about okay
let's go okay
um girls first I do I do want to because
I want to pay tribute to this person so
Michael Lear do you know him he has ALS
no he's a comic he does kill Tony a lot
this isn't a joke against me it's not a
joke but you do you are like the most
ALS without ALS to be on the Earth but
he has like decided to like die by
assisted suicide and he like has been
wavering back and forth he was going to
do it on Halloween and then he decided
not to
and then no that's what I wrote on this
thing going ooh spooky what are you
going as
but he is really like so funny and so
sweet and he's like just been going
through it and so I if if his plan stays
he's been switching back and forth but
of his plan stays sort of like passed
away but I just want to shout him out
because I love him he's such an angel
wow um about suicide like whatever you
want to do baby he's in pain he's like
he but the thing that's like upsetting
to me is the thing that he wrote about
today this is a this is we pre-recorded
this so
but he wrote something where it was like
um it would cost me 200
000 to 500 000 just to keep me alive
wow a year
it's like why like money shouldn't have
to like factor into people's like
decision to live it's like so
frustrating horrible but he's so funny
and
um
yeah I wish I was wearing his merch or
something I have his merch by his merch
for I'm sure the money will go to his
kid or something but he has a kid yeah
he's a son
but he's got an older son he's like but
it's he just is like so funny he dm'd me
I showed Todd because he was like he's
like if I wasn't in this chair would you
have been my girl I was like totally
dude you're so hot and um but he really
is like such a hot funny guy and it was
like you know
but it was like nice to I I mean maybe
he like changed his mind again not to
die he's asking girls if you I love it I
only know what he did but I'm sure he's
hitting everyone up
that's so funny he should does he know
I'm single
everyone knows you're single Biden knows
yourself
come on over Biden
that's the only thing he knows there's
one thing he knows for sure Republican
Annie
oh that's a republican well you what you
just said was that how it sucks that he
has to talk about money when it comes to
his health care
so I just want to say in a political
statement that we should have Universal
Health Care and that Republicans are bad
[Laughter]
make us make a clip of that [ __ ] vote
Jewish
oh my God can you imagine if it was
Bernie
just the elderly LDS man just old man
just crumpled up up there that is what
it is everyone's so old I know what
wasn't Beto supposed to be good who
Beto's what's his name just combined
Beth Bezos and Beto O'Rourke Beto Beto
Beto Beto no it's not bet though I swear
it's better though is it better or not I
will not vote for Hawaii with that
pronunciation in his last name Alberto
I'm not doing that I'm not rolling my
R's with no r in it yeah really I'm not
rolling my b
a
oh my God does Hawaii vote Yes I'm
joking is it over but anyway shout out
to wherever whatever Michael Laird just
chooses I love him I want to say this
like I watched a documentary on assisted
suicide
um and
what I find the most interesting is
choosing the time
and
um some from what I saw on the
documentary it's like usually it's after
about of like extreme pain extreme like
discomfort and then they go through a
period of like maybe three four days of
feeling good again so imagine how that
decision how all of that is factored in
well that's why it's like whatever he
like just decides it's like I support
him because he might change his mind
again right and also it's like
I me if I was gonna go I would take into
consideration how my son remembers this
I don't want it to be around his
birthday like I would Factor so many
things into when I'm departing I hope
it's like a time that is like six months
from his birthday so he doesn't
associate like weird [ __ ] like that one
about his half birthday
oh Esther for half birthdays oh my God
the Jewish people get half birthdays I'm
just kidding no they get a half dollar
for their teeth
I never got a full one did they
um there's this woman on the internet
that says being busy and making that
your whole identity means you don't have
control of your life
explain how do we do we agree with that
people who like you know how they make
one thing their entire identity
and um
she's basically saying that people who
are always like I'm just so busy I'm
overworked like Workaholics
um they have almost
like little to no control of their life
I agree with that because you're being a
victim of your circumstances and you're
letting your circumstances be because
like we all have enough time to do
everything we need to do it's like yeah
I see it more from like you are trying
to distract from everything else by
throwing yourself into your work or
always just constantly moving like you
don't have enough trust in sitting down
and doing nothing because you don't
trust where like how you're feeling when
you're sitting down doing nothing you
don't trust yeah so
um I thought that was interesting
um Esther have you ever been busy
I as a busybody how do you feel about
this I have lots of thoughts so one I've
always thought when people say they're
busy it just mean that they didn't want
to hang out with me so I haven't really
given this this kind of thought but now
that Kendall was really busy
it was busy
my mom that's like when a guy's not
attracted to you and you're like they're
gay
that's what you're doing with Carlos of
course oh I think he's both honestly
both attracted to me and gay
my mom and my sister like literally
can't sit still like especially my mom
like if my parents like we're gonna sit
down and watch a show you get like 30
seconds before she's up fixing things
and I wonder if there's some sort of
mental disorder behind it
do you does your mom like the minute she
comes to your house just to clean
everything
yeah
but it is more so at her house it's like
there is no sitting still and she cannot
understand the concept of if something
needs to get done doing it later like
there's no doing it later I admire that
it's always done right now like it and
we're we like don't speak the same
language because we're so different yeah
regard
I don't know I wonder what that means
but you never even had a chance to do
things right away because your mom would
just have done it yeah not that you want
to do let's be wrong
[Laughter]
but I will say that since I have been
doing more stuff around the house lately
just like you know folding laundry doing
the dishes and stuff like you do get
like a dopamine fix from doing it and it
does get a little addicting so but you
have to like do it like I will go so
long without finishing a task like I
will just add I will like find a thing
on YouTube about like organizing my room
and I will get step two to step two and
there are ten steps okay and what will
happen is step two will just be
everything I own in bags
that never get cleared and so what I do
is I take too much of the dopamine hit
from just like being proud of myself for
getting to step two that I never get to
step ten but if you do like trick
yourself into that feeling of the
accomplishment you can like chase that
for a while but God damn I imagine
you're that person who goes in with the
idea that I'm gonna clean out my entire
closet and then you find one Luchador
mask and then it just completely derails
I'm like grab the green screen babe
we got some promos to shoot exactly
uh I got a [ __ ] promote Cancun
wait what happened who did that who did
that who took Mexico away from Kyle
thought Kyle thought he had an answer to
that Kyle our old host oh yeah Kyle last
week
what happened to Kyle he had to go he
had too many inflammatory uh things to
say about male comedians yeah I heard he
used to use some words he had some
Choice words I hooked up with him and uh
that's why he left and he sued me
you guys thank you so much for joining
us for after dark we are just so ready
to rock and roll baby it's gonna be
incredibly wild there will be dental
dams got the live stream literally this
week
we have a lot in store and it's we're
also going to be reading the comments
while you guys we're going to be
interacting with you we're going to make
out with dental dams right maybe more
okay maybe more
yeah it's this Thursday November 17th at
what time does it start P 7 P.M 7 P.M
baby
trash Tuesday
see you guys come hang out with us
[Music]